we might not be seeing another star wars
film for a while but in the meantime at
least we have a billion superhero movies
to keep us going I'm Kate and this is
your gamespot news update the x-men
movies were among the first in the wave
of modern superhero movies and the
series is still going strong Xmen
apocalypse the sick film in the
franchise arrives in cinemas in may and
now a bumper batch of imagery has been
released while Xmen apocalypse sees many
of the cast from the previous two movies
return there are some new Mutant faces
in there among them is Olivia Munn
playing telekinetic villain psylocke in
a recent interview with Collider the
actress described her characters powers
psylocke is telepathic and telekinetic
she said in the movie we see how being a
telekinetic we don't see her being
telepathic it's a decision we made
because this is the first time we've
really been able to see the character of
psylocke and have her really truly exist
in the movie when you're telepathic I
feel that its power you want to hold
close to your chest Mun also addressed
the issue of her distinctive costume I
know that Psylocke is dressed very
sexually she admitted out of all the
costumes it's really revealing but it's
important to know that she always had
substantive plot lines I can see the way
that she's dressed but it has nothing to
do with how strong she is and how
powerful she is Xmen apocalypse is
directed by bryan singer and is due for
release on May twenty 7 2016 it stars
Michael Fassbender James McAvoy Jennifer
Lawrence Oscar Isaac Nicholas Hoult and
Rose Byrne so what do you think so far
let me know in the comments or come and
find me on Twitter I'm at how not to
draw thanks for watching and for all
your gaming and entertainment news keep
it gamespot